the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet
stop watching because there's some
serious spoilers about to come up but if
you have seen an Avengers end game enjoy
the trailer everywhere I go I see his
face
listen yeah I miss him too I don't think
Tony would have done what he did if he
didn't know that you were gonna be here
after he was gone
you gonna be a next Iron Man now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation heads up
Nick Fury is calling you I don't really
want to talk to me resolve why because
if you don't talk to him and I have to
talk I don't wanna talk so you sent Nick
Fury to voicemail I gotta go you do not
ghost Nick Fury that dorks what's up
we're just talking about the trip I'm
here in st. Marco Polo oh I think MJ
really likes me
how about when I first went alone you're
a very difficult person to contact
spider-man this is mr. Beck we could use
someone like you on my world new world
Beck is from Earth just not ours the
snap to our hole in our dimension we
have a job to do
you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld captain are
unavailable but who's the friendly
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl who I really like
and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course I mean
it's kind of obvious you're right you
may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
starwars feel like I'm putting my
friends in danger the world needs the
next Ironman you're going to step up or
not
[Music]
guys outta here y'all check I work with
spider-man you were through spider-man I
work with spider-man not for spider-man
[Music]